SPEAKER 1: Welcome everybody.
Thank you for joining us.
We have a wonderful
agenda planned
packed with viewings, and
a wonderful discussion
with our panel here from
all around the world, mostly
Alaska.
But I know you didn't come
here to listen to me talk.
So I think we're
gonna go ahead and get
started with our first film.
And then, go from there.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What's the best fisherman?
Is the best freshman the one
that makes the most money?
Is the best fisherman the one
that catches the most fish?
that catches the biggest fish?
To me, the best fisherman is
the one that has the best fish.
It's a stunning landscape.
The watershed is one of the
most healthy salmon watersheds
in all of North America.
Most watersheds can only handle
one or two species of salmon.
But Taku has all five
species of salmon.
What that means
for our fishery is
that we can provide commercially
viable salmon sustainably
harvested for five to six
months out of the year.
There's almost no other river
system that you can do that.
The inlet itself is stunning.
Absolutely stunning.
I love the quote, the
silence is deafening.
You want people
to taste the smell
of Alaska, the fresh
ocean air, the stillness.
To be humbled by the
quality of what is here.
What Taku River Red
had done differently
on the boats is everything to
the fish by proper handling,
making sure that
the fish are not
bound by gravity, rapid
chilling, getting the blood out
is key, and we do that
with a hypodermic needle.
And we actually pump the
blood out within moments
of the fish coming on board.
It's the blood that
makes fish taste fishy.
It's not the meat.
It's just the blood.
So we want to get the blood
out before it coagulates deep
inside the capillaries.
I want you to taste a sockeye.
I want you to taste a coho.
I want you to taste a king
and know the difference.
And you can tell that
by removing the blood.
-We've always felt like our
fish is of the highest quality
because we're doing
everything we know of
to preserve that quality.
But that's all subjective.
To have a scientist use a
machine that objectively
tells us those numbers
and says, yes, you're
doing the right thing with
this fish is really very cool.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
-Everything else we do is for
the health of salmon fisheries.
-Over the years, our
habitat conservation efforts
at Taku River Reds have
become just as important
as the fishing,
and the processing,
and the handling of the fish.
-Nobody here wants to
catch the last fish.
It's too scary to think
of the other options.
That what we have
today might not
be around in a very near future
if you don't take care of it
and protect it.
There are no employees.
Just the six of us.
-We're a group of fishermen
and fishing families.
What it means to us
is not just being
able to eat the finest
fish on the planet.
But when you fish
for your family,
the goal isn't really
to the pocketbook.
It's about fishing
for the future.
-It is not making a living.
We're doing things that
touch people in a certain way
because they're getting
a piece of Alaska.
They're getting
something that they
know is the highest quality.
They're supporting
our way of life,
our fisherman's way of life.
There's a lot more beyond
just going to the store
and buying something to eat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Thank you
everybody for showing up today.
Thank you especially
to Auggi and Vicki
who have been working with me
for the last couple of months
to put this together.
We're really excited to be here.
Again, my name is Jill.
And I'm here from
Juneau, Alaska today
on behalf of Salmon
Beyond Borders, which
is a campaign that
is a collective group
of different interests ranging
from commercial and sport
fishermen to tribes, and First
Nations to municipal leaders
throughout the region, business
owners to operators that
are all working to raise
awareness for this resource
that we're here today that
brings us together today
and in different components,
kind of, unites our work.
And that resource
is wild salmon.
And that resource is currently
threatened in Southeast Alaska
by development upstream
in British Columbia.
So I think it's
important to mention
at the forefront of
this presentation,
and I do this in
all my talks, but I
want to suggest that this is
not an anti-mining campaign.
In fact, on my flight
down here-- and
I've certainly had quite a
few interesting conversations
in all of my
travels from Juneau.
You know, people say
where are you from.
And it, kind of, goes
on its own course.
But when you tell them
you're from Alaska
and that you work for
a salmon conservation,
they say, what are you against?
This is common.
And it just happened on my
way down here, actually.
This woman said-- she was
a planner from Seattle--
she said, what are you
campaigning against?
And we like to say that we're
campaigning or advocating
for salmon.
But it's not just salmon.
It's a livelihood.
It's something that allows
fishermen, and families,
and traditional lifestyles
to maintain and continue.
And what I get to
do is work with all
these different interest
groups to ensure
that that system, and that
cycle, and that lifestyle
can continue for the present
and generations to come.
So I'm just gonna give
you a quick background
of the issue itself.
And we, as a campaign--
the Salmon Beyond Borders
campaign-- produced
a six minute film,
which will show again
before we break out
into a panel discussion.
But feel free.
This is really informal.
If you have a question
along the way, please, just
raise your hand.
Let me know.
Otherwise, we'll have plenty
of time for a question
and answer afterwards.
So starting from, kind
of, the beginning rather.
In 2014, there was a
Northwest transmission line
completed in British Columbia.
Northwest British
Columbia is an area
that has about 2,000 people.
So it's, kind of, in the
middle of nowhere, right.
And so when this power
line was completed,
it created this
chaotic craze, rather,
to start development to start
any type of project that
could be started.
73% of the world's
mining companies
are based in Vancouver.
So that's just one start
of this flow and momentum.
And then also, the former
prime minister of Canada,
Harper, under his
administration,
all federal environmental
regulations were deregulated.
And this created, kind of, a
free for all, more or less,
for exploration of development.
And if you look at different
websites and different maps,
I think that-- can
we go to the map?
It's just a slew.
There's a plethora of
different projects ranging.
Different types of mining
all throughout the region.
But we, the Salmon
Beyond Borders campaign,
is primarily focused on this
Northwest, British Columbia,
Southeast, Alaska region.
And again, I'm
from Juneau, which
is on this side of the map.
It's the capital of Alaska.
We have about 30,000 people.
And in Southeast Alaska, there's
about 75,000 people total.
On that side of the other
side of the border in British
Columbia, there's 2,000.
So again, it's not a
heavily populated area.
And the size itself
is similar to that
of the country of France.
So it's this gigantic region.
Not a lot of people.
Not a lot of people
know about it.
And there are these different
mines that we're focusing on.
Again, 10 because of their
size, scale, and scope,
and their proximity
to Alaska that we're
highlighting and working to
raise awareness for because we
don't have any say.
As downstream interests, those
of us in Southeast Alaska,
there are no established
protections for us
to protect and ensure long-term
water quality and enforceable
protections to our fisheries
and the industries that
keep Alaska going in Southeast.
So again, I'll give
you a quick example.
The KSM Project, which is down
here in the Unuk watershed,
that project was approved by
the provincial and federal
governments in Canada.
It would be the largest open
pit mine in North America
and the fifth
largest in the world.
That's 19 miles
upstream from Alaska.
And it runs into
Misty Fjords National
Monument, which is a federally
protected area, obviously.
And I'll mention also that all
of Southeast Alaska-- this area
through here-- is under
protection of the Tongass
National Forest, which is
the largest National Forest
in the United States.
So on our side, the United
States side of these rivers,
you have the largest
or the highest level
of federal protections.
And on the BC side,
it's under development.
The current premier of British
Columbia, Christy Clark,
wanted her legacy to
be in this region.
10 mines in 10 years.
And she's exceeded that as far
as what stages of development
these mines are in.
So again, our main
ask is that we're
raising awareness to this
issue, to this region that
is unpopulated.
That we're giving a voice
to the commercial fishermen,
to the tribal governments,
to the tour operators that
rely on healthy
fisheries and clean water
to continue to draw tourists and
fishermen in for sport fishing.
So we, over the years,
have been trying
to figure out what type
of enforceable mechanisms,
different policies,
international policies,
are out there and available to
influence these standards that
will guarantee protections
for generations to come.
And really, that's our target.
That's our ask is that under the
Boundary Waters Treaty, which
was signed by both
countries in 1909,
we have the authority to have
a say as United States citizens
and downstream
stakeholders in Alaska
to determine how these globally
significant watersheds are
developed.
So again, just trying to
get that seat at the table.
It's a complex,
convoluted issue involving
different international laws
and different interests.
But it's been an
incredible issue
in that it has brought together
all sectors of Southeast
Alaska ranging from the tribal
governments to the business
owners to our
congressional delegation.
Alaska's congressional
delegation, which are all ours,
very strong conservatives
have supported us
through this effort
in a sense that this
is our way of life
in Southeast Alaska
and the majority of the state.
Salmon is our way of life.
In Southeast Alaska alone,
there's a $2 billion industry.
Commercial fishing,
$1 billion annually.
Tourism, $1 billion annually.
These industries are dependent
upon these clean waters.
And we maintain that we should
have a say in how these shared
watersheds are developed.
So getting back to the
fact that it is clunky
and before I continue
to ramble, we
have explored
different ways in which
we can help tell our story.
How do we raise awareness?
How do we get someone in the
middle of the United States
or a Bay Area of California
to really care or be
aware of this issue?
And through that, we have had
great contacts with filmmakers,
and brother-in-laws working
for Google, and chefs.
Throughout the country,
it's been extraordinary.
And last summer in
particular, a very good friend
of mine in Juneau is gaining
momentum and attention
as a chef.
He, last year, was a
James Beard nominee.
He was also awarded
America's Greatest Seafood
Chef at a seafood
cook-off in New Orleans.
So he's gained a
lot of attention
and is utilizing that attention
to help raise awareness
to the importance of sustainable
fisheries throughout Alaska.
Last summer, we hosted this
small, sustainable seafood
dinner in Juneau that
was mostly local folks.
And it had a great return.
It got media attention that was
syndicated all the way from San
Francisco to Miami.
We had a chef from the Bay Area.
Ritchie, who was supposed to
be here today, unfortunately,
had to deal with some
restaurant issues
and is unable to join us.
But he was here last year.
We had a chef from Houston
and a chef from Seattle.
And that was great.
And so Chef Bo and
I wanted to just
make this bigger and better.
And through the utilization
of products like Kirk's Fish,
he has continued to just
have great attention.
And chefs throughout the country
have been drawn to his work
and what he is
trying to accomplish.
And so this summer,
we-- just in July--
put together the first
inaugural southeast feast,
which was an event
to raise awareness
for the bounty of
Southeast Alaska
and the importance of
sustainable fisheries.
That event brought up
chef Trevor and Tim
who are here with us today.
And we'll get to hear from
them a little bit later.
But it was an
incredible success.
And we had 400 people show
up to this event to just eat
wild Alaskan seafood.
And so through that, through
the film you're about to see,
we've been able to attract
a different attention
and a different care or
concern for this issue
as it relates to how we
connect with people, like what
we're eating, right.
So with that, I think we'll
go into our short film.
And then, we'll be here
to answer any questions.
So thank you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Our natural surroundings
here really define
how we live our lives and
how we relate to each other.
-There's energy.
There's a pulse, you know.
It's almost like being in a
big city or the stock market,
you know.
You're wheeling.
You're dealing.
Things are moving.
-These wild Alaskan
salmon, or maybe they're
wild Canadian salmon.
You know, they're
feeding the world!
-I saw a piece of
Alaska's fishery.
It's over a billion dollars.
Tourism is over a
billion in the industry.
-I can't think of
much money that I've
made in my life that
wasn't because of fish.
-Four words, man.
Humpies pay the bills.
-Huge, huge, huge.
I mean, it doesn't
get any bigger.
This is it.
It's like the farmer depends
on rain for his crops.
You know, we depend on our
environment for these fisheries
that we're all involved in.
-Yes, that's British Columbia.
And yes, this is Alaska.
But as far as the
fish, and the nature,
and the essence of the
river, there's no line there.
-The bulk of these fish are
coming back to these three
big trans-boundary rivers.
The Taku, Stikine, and Unuk.
And if you see impacts
to the fish in there,
those impacts are gonna
cascade across southeast Alaska
through the different
economic sectors.
No matter where you fish
in Southeast Alaska,
you're probably
at risk from some
of the effects of these mines.
-All this mining.
Proposed mines are taking place
across the border in Canada.
So we're not going to see
any kind of economic benefit.
The only thing we're going
to see in this region
is the environmental risks.
-I mean, when I became aware of
this scale the mines proposed.
-The tailings dams
up there are gonna
have to contain several billion
tons of acid generating rock.
That stuff has to be kept
out of the waters forever.
Forever is a hell
of a long time.
-I haven't seen data
that convinces me
that we have that capability
in those kind of rugged places.
And I'm not even
entirely convinced
that that's their highest goal.
-There has been a
lot of deregulation
for environmental
protection in Canada
and in BC with the very
transparent agenda of pushing
as many new mines
through as possible.
-You know, when our people
asked about the tailings
and whether they were safe,
the answer was always the same.
It's the exact same
structure as Mount Polley.
And it's safe.
It's perfectly safe.
It's a perfectly safe.
-The area is
really, really lush.
Lots of clean water and
lots of cedar trees.
And it's this really
special place.
And this happened right
before the salmon were coming.
-Maybe the worst
environmental disaster
in British Columbia's history.
10 million cubic meters
of waste water containing
dangerous chemicals poured
into local waterways
when the earthland dam
surrounding a tailings
[INAUDIBLE] collapsed.
-The technologies,
the experts, everybody
was on deck when they
built Mount Polley
Mine as the shiny example of
new mining in British Columbia.
And it failed in
less than 20 years.
This disaster, what happened
down in Quesnel Lake,
that's our children's
inheritance.
This is what we're leaving them.
-Is there any sense
of how much cost it
would be to put the dam back?
And what kind of insurance
coverage do you have?
-Um.
-Seeing is believing, yep.
But try it on a scale
seven times bigger.
-Tribes.
Commercial and sport fishermen.
Subsistence fisherman.
A lot of the local governments.
Right now, you've got almost
all sectors of Southeast
in agreement that these
BC mines are a threat
to our interest over here.
There's not enough
controls on them.
And we want more
engagement from the state
of Alaska and the US Feds.
-What would you say
to Secretary Kerry?
-I would say that he
has a responsibility
to protect, probably, the last
pristine piece of the United
States, and do it with
everything he has.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: So thank you.
I think we'll just
introduce ourselves.
And then, I think Audrey has
a couple questions that she
can help get the ball rolling.
But again, Jill Weitz.
I am down here from
Juneau, Alaska.
My background is in
environmental policy.
Prior to working on the Salmon
Beyond Borders campaign,
I was a compliance and
enforcement officer
for the state of Alaska.
And I traveled around the state
inspecting mines and seafood
processing plants,
actually before I decided
that I wanted to be
on the other side
and help ensure that these
companies are held accountable,
and their permits are enforced.
And this journey has
been quite fantastic
just being able to work
with different folks
throughout the British
Columbia and Alaskan region.
And I've learned a
ton along the way, so.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Cool.
Hi.
Kirk Hardcastle.
I'm up and down from here in
that I'm a [INAUDIBLE] cowboy
born and raised here
in Sonoma County.
And I, pretty much,
followed my palate in life.
And it led me to
finding the finest
seafood in the entire
planet that I could eat.
And that led me up
into Alaska to become
a commercial fisherman.
I've been working in the-- if
you grew up in Sonoma County,
you either make wine or you
work in the food industry.
And I worked in
the food industry.
So I really just kept
chasing food all my life.
And it led me up there to really
just trying to find the finest
fish that I could.
Coincidentally, I
came from-- anybody
who knows where the
Russian River is.
And it's a big part is that,
just a couple generations
before me, it was said
that salmon were stacked
like cordwood on the river banks
before the industries had come
in and decimated the habitat.
How many salmon
did I grow up with?
I'm almost 50.
How many salmon did I grow
up with in my generation
on the river banks?
Zero.
So to think that if the
generations in the past
had the wherewithal to engage
themselves in an industry
like you to show that you
can vote with your fork
by voting for salmon,
even though it's
a long distance away
but as a concept
to understand that when you
go to these guy's restaurants
and you ask for a wild
fish, you're not only
supporting fisherman's
way of life, once again.
But also management practice,
and environmental conservation,
and natural resource
extraction industries that
promotes for sustainable,
resilient practices
that maintain primary economic
drivers within the region.
Pulling away wild salmon
fisheries in Alaska,
since fisheries are a
primary economic driver,
it would be like pulling
Google out of here.
That's a big deal.
Up there, that's who
we are and what we are.
And how do you maintain
these primary economics
within that region that are
important to the people that
live there?
And we want to be able to
maintain our way of life.
I want to know that generations
from now that salmon
will be on the riverbanks.
If the generations before me, my
great, great grandparents ever
knew or thought that
I would not grow up
with salmon on
the banks, I think
they would have thought
twice about what they did.
And it led me to go up to
Alaska because, darn it, I
wanted to eat some salmon.
So I became a commercial
fisherman up there.
I now have a company.
And I move fish across
the entire United States.
And as you saw in our video,
I'm not about abundance.
I'm not about quantity.
I'm about quality.
The quality of
life, the feeling,
the passion that the
fish can bring to you,
and I hope you get to taste it,
especially in the sushi here
today.
So thank you for being here.
I'm honored that you even
think of seafood and salmon.
And these chefs make it
impossible to bring it
as a vehicle to you.
And it's ever essential.
We do what we do in Alaska.
And you consume what
you consume down here.
But having the chefs involved
is paramount and their awareness
of what they're doing
and how they're moving it
to you to make sure that
you have the best experience
so that you get to taste the
feeling, the air, the passion
of Alaska.
So thanks to the
chefs, primarily
because they make
it so we can eat.
TREVOR KUNK: Awesome.
My name's Trevor Kunk.
Most recently, I was
cooking in the Napa Valley.
But I am actually
departing this week
to go back to the East Coast
back to Brooklyn, New York.
Not nearly as old as Kirk.
[LAUGHTER]
But I have-- well maybe.
I mean, I've been chasing
perfect food, as well,
ever since I discovered
it when I was
seven, eight, nine years old.
I was always in the kitchen.
But I'm from Florida originally.
And as a child
growing up in Florida,
you would go to a restaurant.
And they would call
it Florida seafood.
And there was the scallops.
It was a shrimp.
But scallops don't
really come from Florida.
And the oysters that
they were serving
were much larger than you
would actually get there.
So over the years, I've
had different revelations
in regards to seafood.
And it's something that
I'm obsessed with, just
like everybody that's
sitting here right now
and the chefs that were
up in Alaska with us.
And it goes back to being
a chef, being a consumer,
and being a father.
Like, I want to
know where my food's
coming from because I'm going
to be serving that to my family.
I'm gonna be serving
that to the guess.
it to the friends.
And being able to go to Alaska,
and connect with somebody
like Kirk, and see where
that fish is coming from
was amazing.
And that's really what I was
looking for on that trip.
And I'm just very thankful
that got to happen.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Thank you.
TREVOR KUNK: Yes.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Appreciate it.
TIM ARCHULETA: Hi,
I'm Tim Archuleta.
I'm the owner and executive chef
of Ichi Sushi in San Francisco.
I've been making
sushi for 21 years.
And it's on the forefront of our
website or on our menu at Ichi.
But we consider ourself
self-sustainable sustainable
restaurant.
I don't like-- you
know, there was
a big fad there for a while.
A lot of restaurants opened
up sustainable restaurants.
Carrying a limited amount
of fish because these
were sustainable fish.
We don't put that in the front.
I want you to taste
the food before I
want you to taste a gimmick.
But the sustainability
is very important to me
not only because
of what I'm gonna
leave for the next generation,
but also it's job security.
I'm a sushi chef.
That's what I do.
If I don't have
fish, I'm screwed.
[LAUGHTER]
Veggie sushi is
only so delicious.
[LAUGHTER]
So it really is.
I think about it all the time.
I think about what
is happening and what
we see in the industry for
being there for 21 years.
You see eel, fresh water eel.
First of all, it's
a weird thing.
They don't serve fresh water
eel in Japanese restaurants
or Japanese sushi bars in Japan.
You go to an unagi
place that serves it,
they grill it, they
put it on rice,
bowl, and that's how you eat it.
You would never eat it
in a sushi restaurant.
Here in America, we
love it because it's
one of the five
things you can get,
pretty much, at every sushi
restaurant in America.
Salmon, tuna,
hamachi, eel, shrimp.
Right?
Every restaurant has that.
You come to ours, you're
gonna see things you've never
seen in your entire life.
You'll see some of
those things also.
But with how they're caught
and-- I know this is going
to be a little [INAUDIBLE]-- we
do carry some farm raised fish.
But it's raised in a way
that I feel is sustainable,
and you're using practices
that we agree with.
Sustainability.
This thing of sustainability
is interesting
because you think
about it of, like, OK,
how is it being caught?
I know you probably get this
also, being sustainable.
But it's coming from Alaska.
It's so far away.
We get most of our
fish from Japan.
And there's planes coming
every day from Japan
that they have a special little
holder that hold our fish that
come in from there.
So it's not like a special
flight coming down.
It's the same thing with
the way that the salmons
being shipped down here.
This is all coming in
on commercial airplanes.
So you can do a lot of
research on sustainability.
And you can do as much
homework as you can and still
not really know if something
is 100% sustainable.
So for us, we try to
learn as much as we can.
We go with that.
But with issues like
polluting the water and stuff
like this-- going
up to Alaska, we
went out for a day on the boats.
And got to see the
different types of fishing
that they did up there.
And it was incredible
to actually see
the people who are-- I mean,
this is their livelihood.
And the whole town of Juneau,
pretty much, is salmon crazy.
I mean, Trevor got
a salmon tattoo.
[LAUGHTER]
Actually, three of those
chefs got salmon tattoos.
TREVOR KUNK: Right.
Maybe the year before.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Yeah.
TIM ARCHULETA: Right.
TREVOR KUNK: Yeah.
TIM ARCHULETA: So like, this
is like how ingrained it is.
Like, there is an actual tribal
picture for a salmon up there.
It's part of their lives.
It's, kind of, like how
I go with the sustainably
[INAUDIBLE].
It's part of my life.
It's important to me.
It's how I make a living.
It's how I pay the bills.
So going up there and being
able to see the process
to be able to talk to the people
to see how it's processed,
you know, we get all of our
salmon roe comes from Alaska.
And to be able to go to
the actual processing plant
and see how it's
actually done, and see
it is there before it comes to
my restaurant was incredible.
And you know, Kirk said
something about voting
with your fork.
I think that's something that's
very, very, very important.
Voting with your fork is--
you know, if you love salmon,
and you're not
quite sure if it's
from a farm from
somewhere that's
not using sustainable
practices, don't buy it
if you're not sure.
If the fishermen can't tell you,
or the guy at the meat counter
can't tell you where it's
from or not quite sure,
it's better not to get
it, to be honest with you
because it's affecting
that greatly.
Again, 21 years, eel.
Eel, you used to be able
to get in abundance.
Now it's really hard to get.
Why?
Because they are fishing
it unsustainably.
Bluefin tuna.
We don't carry bluefin
tuna at the restaurant.
People lose their minds.
They get so mad at me.
Why don't you have toro?
And I said because it
comes from bluefin tuna.
Oh, but the stocks are back up.
Yeah, you can research that,
and look on the internet.
But are you sure
they're really back up?
I mean, Japan has
warehouses beyond warehouses
beyond warehouses
full of frozen tuna
because they know,
at some point,
it's not going to be around.
And they have stockpiles
of it because they
know it's gonna be
worth a lot of money
because people want it.
We don't carry it.
It's not sustainable.
I don't want to decimate
a fish off the planet
because I want to serve--
because it tastes delicious.
Voting with your fork, I think,
is one of the coolest things
that I've heard at this panel.
And I think it's something that
we need to take very seriously.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: I'd like
to add on to that really
quick in regards to
Alaska is that the way we
manage our fisheries is a
sustainable management system.
And yes, they do
have to get flown.
And so that's
where you, kind of,
go through the
compromise of flying.
You realize, wow, there's
a big carbon footprint.
Is this, like, truly
on the whole gamut
of the word of sustainability.
It's a really green-washed
word these days.
Unless you really get in
the specifics of what you're
looking at, you
can pick and pull
the definition of sustainability
out in a lot of funny ways.
But what we mean by voting with
your fork is saying, when you
say I want to eat that
and voting with your fork,
I'm putting money towards
this economic resource that's
a management system that is
making sure that there will be
that fish, not for
you, not for your kids,
for the great,
great grandparents
and the great, great grandkids.
And that's the main
goal is to make sure
that those fish can still
be in the river systems
on your plate.
And when you vote
with your fork,
you're saying I approve of this
system that will, hopefully,
be around much longer
than I will be.
And so I just ask for the
most sustainable, most wild,
as far as a management system
or harvesting practices
that you can possibly find.
That was a question that
came up in our other panel.
How do we know?
How do we know
what we're buying?
If you, basically,
just really focus
on sustainability
of the harvest,
as well as if you can ask
for wild as much as you can,
but it does come with the
depleted stocks, as well.
As a gross generalization,
wild from Alaska,
you're doing pretty
darn well cause
it's in article eight of
the Alaska constitution.
It's part of who we are, like
the American Constitution
of freedom of speech and
many other of these rights
that are just core to the
being of the United States
that are very
unique in the world.
Core to the being of
Alaska is in Article eight
of the Alaska constitution.
And that is to maintain
sustainable fisheries forever.
So that's key for us, as well.
So thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's really
hurting me more.
You can imagine what I saw with
the mining and the accidents
and all.
British Columbia is home for us.
We became a family there.
All these things
were very important
when we lived there, as well.
They remain important.
But before we get this
into, kind of, the bashing,
I just would like to point
out two things that, I'm sure,
that in the States there
are a lot of bad things
like this happen,
as well elsewhere.
And the other thing is
that I know for a fact
that there are a lot
of people in Canada
who feel the same way
and a lot of people
who fight really hard like
the [INAUDIBLE] Foundation.
I'm sure you're in
contact with them.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Huge respect to them.
I used to work for
them on their website.
But it's really, really
important what you're doing.
And I fully support it.
And you know, voting
with the fork,
we've been doing it for
the last 15 years probably.
Super important And
raising awareness, as well.
So thank you for what you do.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Thank you.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Thank you.
The native groups and people
in the video are from Canada.
It's a big proponent
on that side.
It's very, very
important to us, as well.
And hey, you know, I got
to tell you, I love mining.
Are you kidding?
I have this.
I drive a car.
I drive a boat.
And my boat is a diesel engine.
And operates with
metals and copper.
And I use all the
things from mining.
I love mining.
Irresponsible mining is
a very different story.
And it's kind of like
driving down the highway.
Everybody abides by
the rules of 50 to 55.
And anyone driving a semi
truck at 120 miles an hour,
that's not abiding by
the general common sense
rules of safety and awareness
for a lot of other people.
And there are a lot of Canadians
who support that, as well.
It's mostly just making
sure that everybody
abides by the social
contract that we all
have with each other and
our emotional contract
that we have with the salmon,
as well, to live in unison.
And the giving and
the receiving of what
salmon do for the people
is really important.
AUDIENCE: Yes, and just to say
that the Harper government has
done so much damage.
And I want to end it on a
very positive note that Mr.
Trudeau, like our--
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Trudeau!
AUDIENCE: --prime minister.
Woo hoo.
I'm so, hopeful.
And I really want it to
be a very positive thing.
And I'm really hoping
that he's gonna
pull off what needs to pull
off after what Harper did.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Absolutely.
We've been fortunate enough to
work with an incredible group
of folks from British Columbia,
but also with lawmakers
in Ottawa.
We've had great
meetings that have
folks that are filled with
that same hope, especially
for the region that
we're speaking to.
Last fall, President Obama
and Prime Minister Trudeau
signed the strategic
leadership agreement
for the Arctic region,
which incorporated
the awareness for
indigenous rights
and putting that at the
forefront of decision making,
especially as it relates
to environmental issues
around climate and development.
So there are huge steps
taking place just post-Harper,
which are incredible.
We have a long way to go.
But we know that
we're not gonna get
anywhere without the support
from British Columbia
and Canada.
So we absolutely
don't intend to bash.
We only intend to raise
awareness for the fact
that business can't
continue as usual.
We're not under any illusion
that we're gonna stop mining.
But how can we ensure that the
best available technologies
and practices are
implemented and adhered to?
AUDIENCE: Fully agree.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you speak a little
bit more to the relationship
that you guys have?
And I don't know if it's
specifically your campaign,
but the government
side of things.
Like, how is that relationship
with British Columbia
and with the future
of these mines?
Do you see them
all moving forward?
Or is there some slowdown
because of Trudeau
and because there is
this increased awareness.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Yeah,
that's a really good question.
That's my sister, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
So it is a good question.
And I think that has been
the biggest dynamic feature
of our campaign efforts
is focusing primarily
with the state of Alaska
and the province of BC.
And some of you
may know or may not
know that authority lies
within the province in Canada.
The federal government has
authority over their fisheries.
But all natural resource
development and management
is managed at the
provincial level.
So there's been headway in the
sense that the state of Alaska
is working really close with
the province of British Columbia
to, kind of, improve
transparency,
and correspondence,
and provide opportunity
for involvement, and
for the state of Alaska
to be involved in the
permitting process.
But again, you know,
Canada, they only
have to listen if
they want to, rather.
But at the same time
while this is happening,
we have different
agreements happening
at the federal level and
different regulatory agencies
saying, well, we could do
this, and we could do that.
And again, people
are talking about it.
We have to remind ourselves
not to be discouraged
because this is part
of a conversation that
wasn't two years ago.
So people are talking about it.
And as we know in
bureaucratic systems,
it takes awhile to
get things going.
But on the other side
to that, while we're
having these conversations,
British Columbia
is continuing to permit
and develop these projects.
For example, you
guys saw in that film
the Mount Polley
mine disaster that
happened in Central
British Columbia
into the Fraser River Watershed.
That same mine proprietor,
Imperial Metals,
was authorized three
days after expert panel
review had suggested that
business can't go on as usual.
You can't have wet tailings.
You have to do this.
You have to do that.
And the BC government
said, OK, we're gonna stop.
We're going to try to improve
our practices and enforcement.
But under the table,
three days later,
authorized Imperial Metals
to open a much bigger mine
in the headwaters of
transboundary river,
the Stikine River.
And so its practices
such as that
that make us weary of while
we're doing all these things
and making headways
in certain areas,
they're still pushing
straight ahead.
So it's just continuing
to raise awareness.
It's continuing to
target elected leaders
to write your elected leaders
and suggest that it's not
just about salmon.
It's if we're gonna
do this, if we're
gonna continue to develop and
extract natural resources,
we're in the 21st century.
We have to do it right.
We have to ensure that that
is going into consideration.
KIRK HARDCASTLE:
An add-on to that
one is that when that dam
collapsed and broke free,
that same structural engineer
company style of making dams
is what my thing is
that, OK, we know this.
We don't drive pintos
anymore, people, you know.
Let's stop putting gas
tanks in the back of cars
because rear ends can explode
a car with a family in it.
Those same types of
engineering disasters
aren't being
mitigated and changed
for the next stage of mining
production and development.
Like I said, I'm
all for the mines.
But why build a mining dam that
we know that style breaks free?
And they're permitting to
proceed with that same style
into multiple different
mines across North America.
Why not build a dam that you
know is like the Hoover Dam?
Well it's gonna hold
for a long time.
You know, and just mitigate
that type of thing.
Like Google, you don't
put out a product
that fails in a couple
of months and grossly.
Like, it makes big
time headlines.
Right?
You want to put
out something that
can maintain it's resiliency
in the marketplace,
or structural engineering, or
electrical engineering that
can last for a long, long,
long time, not just something
that you really know
it's gonna break.
And oh, it broke last week.
So let's fix it, and
try and improve upon it.
So that's one of the main
parts with these dams
is that they want to build
the same style of dam
and just say, hey, let's make
a better integrated network
matrix built in the
superstructure of the dam
itself.
AUDIENCE: Is their
model for success
or any sort of
measure or negotiation
that you're really
optimistic about that you can
see as being a real solution?
JILL WEITZ-SALMON:
Yeah, like what
does winning look like to us?
Yeah, absolutely.
My boss asks me
that all the time.
I think that,
first and foremost,
like Kirk was just
mentioning, this wet tailings
design that they've been
operating and approving
throughout British Columbia,
we know that it won't last.
I mean, some of these
pictures might suggest,
but for any of
you that have been
to southeast Alaska or
British Columbia, it's rugged,
steep mountains.
And it's wet.
It's a temperate rain forest.
You're just setting yourself
up for failure in that regard.
So as far as engineering and
structure of the mining goes,
it's been recommended that they
do dry stack tailings, which
is a different type
of tailing storage,
which, seemingly,
it's more contained.
And you don't have this
big, man-made, earthen dam
that is set to fail
and flood and break.
So that's one component of it.
But again, as I
mentioned earlier,
we want to have a
part in determining
what the development
looks like moving forward,
and how these environmental
regulations are strengthened
again, and how indigenous
rights and how indigenous
governments take a huge part
and contribute a huge part
to that process.
And so I think it's, kind
of, all encompassing as far
as what it looks like.
It's ensuring that
this region that
is rich in natural
resources, including salmon,
including minerals, is developed
in as sustainable a way
as we can do.
So without getting
too specific, that's
just the broad landscape.
You know, there have
been a bunch of reports
that have come out, especially
in the last six months,
from British Columbia's own
auditor general suggesting
that British Columbia is
failing on all accounts
to enforce their permits and
protect their environment.
You know, their own auditor
general is suggesting that.
There have been economists that
have done financial assurance
reports that are suggesting
tax payers are liable.
$1.5 million in debt
as far as taxpayers
accountability to pay off
fines for mining companies.
And that's just in this
region, just this region
of British Columbia, not the
entire province as a whole.
So it's things like that where
building awareness to that
and ensuring that these
practices are going to continue
or this industry is
going to continue.
But let's make sure that these
best practices are actually
adhered to.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: For Taku
River Reds, is
mining one of the biggest
issues you see going forward?
Or could you speak to other
problems you might have,
like climate change
in warmer waters?
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Oh, you
ask awesome questions.
Can I be here for
a couple hours?
I would say for
Taku River Reds, I
would say our greatest
hurdle that's coming up
is hoping that all of
you vote with your fork.
To me, it's about
marginalization of an industry.
I would like to see all
of you vote with your fork
rather than sitting
back going, oh,
what are the
government's doing here?
What are the conservation
groups doing here?
You are more powerful than
any government out there.
You are more powerful than any
conservation group out there.
You saying I support salmon,
I support wild seafood,
I support sustainability
is the most powerful thing
anyone can ever do.
And that is by voting with
your fork in those directions.
My example that I used up in
the wine country last night
is, so I grew up
in Sonoma County.
For those of you who
don't know, Sonoma County
built San Francisco.
The natural resources
that were there,
it was the redwoods,
the timber industry.
You could drop one
tree, and you could
build an entire
neighborhood with one tree.
So the timber industry and
the pebble mines there.
The gravel there built the
streets of San Francisco.
The trees built the
buildings of San Francisco.
And the cobblestone
streets, the cobblestones
came from my backyards.
So those places were zoned for
natural resource extraction
at the cost of salmon habitat.
What happened was
the marginalization
of those industries, those
kind of deregulated industries,
those industries
became marginalized
because another industry
came in and said
it's more important to us
to have this new industry.
Guess what that is?
Wine.
You voted with your cork.
You voted with your fork.
You chose something else
out there that you think,
as a people, not waiting
for the government
to decide, not for tree huggers
to say quit cutting down
the redwoods, but
you, as a people,
decided that we want to support
another style of industry
that's in the exact same place.
I grew up in a timber
town in families.
I mean, my friends families
were all part of the timber.
And they had the skill set of
industrial, zoned industrial,
truck drivers, and all
of a sudden someone
says, well, you can cut down
a tree, and get $20 an hour.
Or you can work for the wine
industry for $60 an hour
because people are willing
to vote with their fork, vote
with a cork.
You can marginalize
an industry by you
as individuals out there on what
you buy, and what you support,
and the emotions and
passions that you
bring to it by going to
restaurants like this
and making those requests.
So that's what I
see is our greatest
hurdle is to empower the public
with the seafood consumption.
Let's see, in
regards to the mines,
I try to think
positive in other ways.
But yes, mines are
definitely, without a doubt,
there's an issue in
some of those regards.
The Taku is-- you probably
saw in the video--
it is one of the largest,
most healthy, diverse
watershed ecosystems in all
of North America because
of the genetic
structures that are
built within the salmon
and other species habitats
in there.
AUDIENCE: i understand the
voting with your fork part.
And I think that's
super important.
But I have friends who
are fishermen in Alaska.
And a lot of them haven't been
catching as much as usual.
And so it doesn't matter
if we vote for our fork
if there aren't anymore salmon.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Right.
There will always be
salmon in the future.
They will shut
our fisheries down
before they extirpate
the species itself.
That's unique in Alaska.
They do not manage their
fisheries for my pocketbook
or for your restaurants.
They manage the fisheries
in Alaska-- under Article 8,
we manage the fisheries
for the future.
We fish for the future.
You will never in theory,
unless something dramatically
happens weird, but you
can't extirpate and exhaust
the resource there through
the management system.
So under climate change,
if the fish do decline,
they shut down our fishing days.
So in the Taku
system, I only fish
Sunday, Monday and Tuesday,
sometimes Wednesdays.
If you're a smart fish,
and you're a Taku salmon,
you only swim up there on
Thursday, Friday and Saturday.
Also, they manage
our gear for when we
do put our gear in the water.
They manage our gear
to not catch fish.
So King salmon typically
swim 40 feet and under.
So guess how
shallow our gear is?
30 feet.
Our gear is also designed
so that king salmon
will bounce off the net.
Pardon me, it's not designed.
It's managed to allow these
fish to hit it, and bounce off
and swim.
If there's a
specific run of fish,
they will manage it so they can
actually swim through or gear.
So we're targeting
a specific person.
Like for instance,
if I were to do this,
I would say I'm
gonna set my gear out
to only catch people
in pink dresses, OK,
or guys with beards.
It's that targeted.
Our bycatch in an entire
year, an entire season,
is maybe one bird.
One bird.
That's how targeted
the way we fish.
So fishermen, by nature,
you have some friends.
I'm not your typical fisherman.
Fisherman, I'm supposed
to complain a lot.
You know, I'm supposed to be
like damn this and damn that.
I try to see the more positive
side of how fortunate I
am to be able to have
an abundance of seafood
to be able to harvest and
share with other people.
So the management system
will keep it so that we still
do have fish there.
Climate change is a
big issue, for sure.
The biggest difference I have
on that with climate change
has been the meat quality,
and the fluctuations
in meat quality, and the
changes in the styles of runs.
But the abundance of species
that have the ability
to reproduce and stay
within the carrying
capacity of a
harvestable allotment,
I think we're doing
really well in that.
Climate change is
changing, obviously,
the meat quality more
than anything else, as far
as a big thing.
So climate change is an
issue, but not too much.
AUDIENCE: Following
up on that, do
we need to reframe
this conversation
as a need for regenerative
practices versus sustainable
practices?
Or are we not there yet?
KIRK HARDCASTLE:
Resilient practices.
So one of the key
things is that you
need to have a
sustainable management
bureaucratic system to allow
for resilient business practices
to exist.
Resiliency in business
or management--
any kind of management
system-- resiliency
can't happen at the large
level bureaucratic system
because those types
of systems can't
move in more fast
enough from climate
change, economic
change, volatility
in distribution of
natural resources.
So you have to
have the stability
in a bureaucratic system
of sustainable management
to allow for private
businesses to work resiliency.
So as we were mentioned
about sustainability,
there's market driven
sustainability and
institutionalized
sustainability.
Alaska is not market
driven sustainability,
as Tim was saying.
We are not market driven
sustainability in Alaska.
We are institutionalized
sustainability.
It's not a green watch
stamp to put on there
for selling a product.
So the sustainable layer
of our bureaucratic system
and institutionalized system
allows for resilient business
practices to happen and move
in more for the fluctuations
of the marketplace.
So I agree with
what you had to say.
But that's one of the
unique parts of what Alaska
has over the rest of the world.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm gonna go back to the mining.
My question is,
have the innovations
been developed-- engineering,
technology, whatever-- for what
you would trust in
a mining operation?
Or are we still
trying to invent that?
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Absolutely.
I think that there
are-- I mean, that's
kind of a hard question
to answer in the sense
that there are so many different
scales of mines, right.
And we're talking about
large scale, open pit mines.
We're not talking about
smaller scale mines
like we have throughout
southeast Alaska
that have dry stacked
tailings, have
different mining
life in the sense
that some are 15 to 20 years.
Some are 30 to 40 years, where
these large scale mines are
failing at 14 to
17 years, you know,
and set for longer lifespans.
I think that there is
the technology out there.
And it comes down
to the government
requiring that these
companies implement that.
And it's an economic choice.
It's these mining companies
deciding whether or not
they want to put forth
the money to ensure
that health and safety come
first prior to economic profit.
And so yeah, I can
say confidently
that those
technologies do exist.
And that's what we're advocating
for, that they are implemented.
And at this point, it's kind
of up to the mining company
whether or not they want to
follow through with that, yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] example
of large scale [INAUDIBLE].
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Not to the
scale of these mines, yeah.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: But we have
some very small scale mines
that are very successful
within salmon habitat that
do a fantastic job, for sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
scale that?
KIRK HARDCASTLE: What
does winning look like?
We have plenty of
winning mines, for sure,
in Alaska that do very well.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Yep.
And the fact that these
mines have to be large scale
is the fact that the ore
quality in these regions, it's
really low grade ore.
So they have to extract
a ton of the earth
in order to get profit.
So that's what makes it a
lot messier than practices
that we have throughout Alaska,
for example, that are done
on a smaller operation scale.
Yeah, so she was
asking is it dependent
upon the scale of those mines.
Is it messier, or is it harder
to implement those better
practices because of the scale
as opposed to the smaller
operations and, thus, it's
more affordable for them
to implement best technologies.
Is that, kind of,
what you were asking?
Or did I answer it, kind
of, within another question?
AUDIENCE: Well
I'm just wondering
if they don't do it because they
can't or because they wouldn't
be making as much money.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON:
Yeah, they wouldn't
be doing it because they
won't be making as much money.
Absolutely right.
They absolutely can afford it.
You know, these smaller,
like, junior companies
are adhering to these better
available technologies
than these larger
operations that
want to extract as much as they
can, pull as much as they can,
and get out of there.
AUDIENCE: So as a
chef because you're
kind of working with
the end consumer,
right, like ourselves
going to your restaurants,
enjoying food.
I think you alluded a
little bit like people
going to a restaurant looking
for a sustainable restaurant.
But that message
may not necessarily
be what true
sustainability means.
So how is the chef community is
working with someone like Jill,
like the fishermen, Kirk?
Like, how do you guys do
that within your community?
And also, how do you
translate or educate and share
that knowledge with
your consumer that comes
to your restaurant, et cetera?
TREVOR KUNK: So
can I talk first?
TIM ARCHULETA: Please.
TREVOR KUNK: So I think what you
just said was very important.
You said educate
because we never want
to tell a guest how to eat.
We're never gonna tell
them to do x, y, and z.
But what we can do
is we can educate.
And we can train our
staff, inform them,
and have them then relay that
information to the guest.
Sometimes it's
really, really easy.
Sometimes it's very,
very difficult.
And it really also
depends where you are.
I mean, whether you're
in the Napa Valley,
whether you're in San
Francisco, whether you're
in New York, or New Orleans.
It takes time.
And something that I've
been, kind of, thinking
about even before
I went to Alaska
is-- and this, kind of,
goes back to my childhood--
don't get mad at
me when I say this,
but I don't like salmon, OK.
I don't like salmon.
KIRK HARDCASTLE:
Totally understand.
TREVOR KUNK: But listen.
So the reason I don't like
it is because, for me, I've
been eating the wrong thing
for the past 20, 25, 30 years.
And it's farmed raised garbage.
And over the years-- and when
I say over the years, starting
about eight, nine, 10
years ago, and this
happened to be where I
was working in New York
City-- that's when we started.
We didn't carry salmon unless
it was wild king salmon.
And if wild king salmon
wasn't available,
then we would bring
in sockeye or coho.
But that salmon is a lot
different than the farm salmon
that we're all used to eating.
So I love salmon if it's wild.
If it's the other
notion that people
have of what salmon is,
which is super fatty, super
thick, and just, kind of, odd in
color, I don't like that stuff.
But going back to
the educational part,
like if you have a
guest that's coming in
and they've been coming in
for five years, or 10 years,
and they've been ordering
that same kind of salmon,
it's really hard
to wean them away.
So you just have to,
kind of, take it slowly.
And that's when, again, you
have a very well-informed staff
being able to share with
the guests, like, well,
why don't you have salmon
like you did six months ago?
And the reason is, well,
we're sourcing locally.
We're sourcing seasonally.
We don't want to buy
it from South America.
it from New Zealand.
We want to support
the Alaskan fishery.
And right now, what is available
in five or six months out
of the year is gonna
be sockeye or coho,
and on a more seldom
occasion, king.
AUDIENCE: Anything to add?
TIM ARCHULETA: I
don't know if anybody
have been to my restaurant.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Woo hoo.
JILL WEITZ SALMON:
I have, woo hoo.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Mind boggling!
[LAUGHTER]
Just putting it out there.
TIM ARCHULETA: We're the exact
opposite of what Trevor said.
We do tell people how to eat.
[LAUGHTER]
I have a whole mural, actually,
in the restaurant dedicated
to how to eat sushi properly.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, I am a control freak,
A. But B, also, it's
to help you enjoy the
product the best way.
For us at our restaurant, if you
mix a bunch of wasabi, and soy
sauce, and completely,
you know, don't
drown your food-- [INAUDIBLE]
or the commercials used
to have-- you're
not going to taste
the hard work that this guy
does when he fishes and does
everything he does to keep the
salmon as awesome as possible.
So for us, we do
educate you, regardless
if you want to or not.
You're gonna get educated.
You know, I fight
with customers.
I've throw customers
out of the restaurant
for arguing with soy
sauce and wasabi.
There's a proper amount.
But again, it's all
about education.
Something I wanted to
mention earlier-- this,
kind of, goes with it too
in educating-- seafood
shouldn't be cheap.
You know, we have
this thing we're
we want to be able to provide.
Everybody should have access
to everything, right, which
a lot of the stuff, it's true.
We should have access
to certain things.
But seafood is one
of those things where
I don't know if it should
be accessible to everybody,
and especially at a low price.
It should be more expensive
because the more expensive
it is, then we're not
actually consuming as much.
We're thinking twice about
what we're actually eating.
If we all of a sudden stop
eating chicken and everyone
goes to a seafood
diet, it's gonna
be really hard to be able
to sustain that to be
able to keep up with that.
And we're on the
more expensive side.
I think we're a great
value for what we do.
We carry very high end product.
People complain how expensive
we are all the time.
And for me, it's
educating and saying,
yeah, that's true
because I'm paying
top dollar for my seafood.
I'm paying a lot of money.
If you actually knew how much,
per pound, my fish cost me,
it would blow your mind.
It shouldn't be something that
everybody should have access
to.
It shouldn't be out
there for $1.99.
You shouldn't be eating sushi
that costs, you know, $2 a roll
because we're wiping
it off the planet
with that kind of mentality.
It should be more expensive.
This guy should get
more per pound for his--
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Thank you.
TIM ARCHULETA: --salmon that he
sells because, as you can see,
the abundance is not
there what it used to be.
In California here, we
had three or four years
where the commercial
salmon allotment was
a month or two because
we are decimating
these fish out of the water.
We need to raise our prices.
We need to be really
thinking about what
we're doing to the oceans
because it's a great resource.
But there's not that much fish
out there for the whole world.
I mean, it's also this
weird thing too now.
Like, my wife's from
Flint, Michigan.
When we go to Flint,
Michigan, there's
four sushi restaurant
Flint, Michigan.
Not that the fish isn't fresh.
But just, all of a
sudden, it's everywhere.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: In Flint?
Yeah, I was like, of all places.
TIM ARCHULETA: You
know, so we need
to think about what
we're paying for it.
I think that's something that
we did not talk about here.
Again, it should
be something that's
much more expensive than it is.
AUDIENCE: OK, I have been
googling your restaurant
as you've been talking.
And I cannot get a reservation.
So what is the key to getting a
reservation at your restaurant?
[LAUGHTER]
TIM ARCHULETA: Oh, wow.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: You
got to go in there.
I had to go in there.
TIM ARCHULETA: Under the bus.
[LAUGHTER]
Walk in.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: It's--
TIM ARCHULETA: You might
have to wait a little bit.
But we serve everything in
the whole entire restaurant.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: And they
yell at you when you walk in.
It's fantastic.
TIM ARCHULETA: That's
a positive yell.
Not a--
JILL WEITZ-SALMON:
Yeah, it's a welcome.
KIRK HARDCASTLE:
Food is my life.
That's what I do.
And primarily, seafood.
And I'm, kind of, picky.
That's why I have some of the
finest seafood in the planet,
specifically on the salmon side.
And I was thoroughly impressed
and didn't even flinch
at the dollar signs that
was-- the greatest thing
that we sat down and I hope he
enjoyed it as well is, well,
what would you like?
And we all looked and
said chef's choice.
If you go in, please, all of you
go in at sometime in your life,
and request chef's choice.
And just don't even think about
what you're-- it will be a life
changing experience in regards
to how you approach seafood.
It will change your palette.
It'll change your dreams.
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Chefs are
social media addicts, I think,
where people are addicted
to following their lives.
Taku River Reds, they
have a great website.
salmonbeyondborders.org,
our website,
there's a ton of
information on there.
Ways in which you can take
action, donate, and our film's
on there.
Share the film, et cetera.
Just feel free to
scope us out further.
And we'll be around
here for awhile
if you guys have
questions later on.
Thank you.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: For
me, vote with your fork.
Vote with your cork.
You know, and it doesn't
just go with your food.
Whatever you do in
life, if you support
that style of management
system, that business,
or whatever it is,
vote with your dollar.
It really means a lot.
Government reg-- I'm a
fisherman, so I'm like, ah,
got my regulations, [GRUMBLING].
Hey, in Alaska, there's
barely a single fisherman
that doesn't love
heavy regulations
because if we extirpated and
wasted our resource in five
years-- I don't
know about you guys.
My mortgage is 30.
And if I ran out
of money in five,
I can't pay my
mortgage on anything.
So to know that that resource
is out there long enough
to pay my mortgage
and pay my other bills
is because people like
you vote with your fork.
You say, I want to
support the management
system for sustainable
management systems
as a governmental
institutionalized policy, not
as a market driven, which a
market driven sustainability
is great.
But the way you can set your
government up in regulations
and say we approve
of this style.
You think of Alaskan
fishermen hating government,
hating regulations.
You know what?
We don't hate that.
We love it because it
means we can have it
for our great, great,
great grandchildren.
And we can pay our
bills, as well.
And it's fantastic
for the palate.
And it tastes great.
TREVOR KUNK: Thank you all
very much for having us.
That's it for me.
TIM ARCHULETA: And
don't eat cheap sushi.
[LAUGHTER]
TREVOR KUNK: [INAUDIBLE]?
TIM ARCHULETA: No.
TREVOR KUNK: No?
TIM ARCHULETA: No
buffets, please.
KIRK HARDCASTLE: Oh, and
there's-- is there still more?
JILL WEITZ-SALMON: Yeah,
we got a ton of salmon.
TIM ARCHULETA:
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
KIRK HARDCASTLE: So this is
my fish that are brought here.
It's all the pressure
bled sockeye.
It's not gonna be that
bright, fatty stuff.
You're gonna let the
fish speak for itself.
Please, try it out.
It will not taste what you
expect it to taste like.
It's gonna taste like when your
feet are in the ocean beach
out here.
Your toes are in the
sand, and the waves
are hitting and
that fresh ocean air
that passes through
your palate, that's
what we want you to taste.
So please, you'll probably
never-- well hopefully,
you guys will have this
as a regular menu item.
But right now, it's there.
Please, try it out.
[APPLAUSE]